good morning Hank it's Tuesday here's a
sunset from North Carolina I'm exhausted
and exhilarated from the project for
awesome which this year has raised over
1.3 million dollars for charity the
fundraiser will be up for another couple
days you can learn more at
projectforawesome.com slash donate so
this video is about loneliness and if
you are feeling lonely or concerned
about your mental health there is help
and there is hope okay when I was in my
mid-20s I experienced a bout of intense
loneliness and isolation that was
correlated with serious depression I was
living in an apartment building with
very thin walls and so I could hear
people all the time and I had a job so I
saw people every day including people
who cared about me and thanks to the
emerging tools of the internet I could
instant message with anyone I knew
anywhere in the world any time I wasn't
short on connective opportunities I was
just short on connection and the more
isolated I felt the less capable I felt
of escaping isolation when I did talk to
people I often couldn't listen to them
well or engage deeply with them because
I was so overwhelmed by my own sadness
and worry but that's just one of the
many vicious cycles of loneliness
feeling isolated made me feel unworthy
of love which made me feel more isolated
the thought of calling people I'd long
failed to call flooded me with dread
which made me less likely to call them
and feeling despair made me feel useless
which made me feel more despair one of
the big challenges of isolation for me
is that I start to feel as if the whole
thing is meaningless human consciousness
is an absolute wonder I mean how wild is
it that our mind can conceive of the
infinite from within a finite universe
but when I'm really lonely I start to
feel like my consciousness isn't for
anything like it isn't serving any
shared or greater purpose I sometimes
feel as if my life is just circling its
own misery like a vulture over a carcass
and that pain makes me want to withdraw
further from the stupid world with its
stupid people who believe in stupid BS
which in turn were since the pain of
meaninglessness and furthers my
isolation and so on
I'm situating this video in the deep
past of 20 years
ago but the truth is that a similar
feeling of isolation began to pull me
under much more recently I again started
to feel separate from the world and like
everything was a sick joke and even
though I had friends and family members
who loved me I still felt as if I was
floating away from all of them in both
cases these cycles were broken in the
end by treating my chronic health
problem like a chronic health problem
which for me means taking medication and
going to therapy regularly but it also
means understanding that loneliness is a
problem I need to address actively by
being intentional about finding or
refined in community this is hard at
first breaking cycles always is but it
gets easier and it's always worth the
trouble some of the communities have
become more involved in our built around
a shared enthusiasm Liverpool Football
Club for instance others are built
around activism or around my physical
neighbourhood quitting the social
Internet has also helped me to address
my loneliness because I used those
platforms so unhealthily by engaging in
superficial connection that left me
feeling deeply alone but it is not only
IRL communities that can run deep as I
was reminded this weekend although I'm a
very introverted person for me feelings
of meaning and purpose flow from the
experience of deep connectedness of
being part of communities that are
bigger than me but nonetheless value and
include me I hope some of you felt that
way during the project for awesome this
year I know that for me the p4a showed
up when I really needed to be reminded
that what we can accomplish together
is truly cause for hope Hank I'll see
you on Friday